how do you find the line between
extremely physical extreme physical
wrestling and rough wrestling or angry
wrestling so to which degree has anger
whether it's in your wrestling room
these days or in your own career entered
wrestling do you see it as a tool that
can be
used
in the wrestling match i think there's a
balance and or not even a male there's a
line that you go up to and you can't
cross it sportsmanship is everything you
can get dinged for points you can get
thrown out of tournaments there's rules
with um
flagrant misconduct where you're kicked
out of the match
other team gets the points and then you
have to sit the next meet
so it's very serious the ncaa
sends a message a very serious message
about sportsmanship yeah and so we talk
about that the other thing with
wrestling is there's rules in wrestling
these guys that are tough guys
outside of the rules
that's that's what you want in your
opponent that means they're frustrated
you got to be a you got to be a tough
guy inside the rules of the sport
that's that's more honorable than cold
cocking somebody and knocking them out
so yeah anger doesn't mean breaking the
rules but i mean you know you
a lot of people know you just watching
you as a coach
there's quite a bit of passion there
well come and do what you're doing
tonight i mean break bread with me in my
kitchen and see how big of a jackass i
am now you're a pretty nice guy well i'm
not asking for that necessarily but
thanks i'm saying
you know what you you as a coach i mean
come okay come spend a month in our
program and you'll see really what kind
of
what kind of people we are
and there's a stigma out there because
they are very threatened by our program
there's nobody else that threatens
the sport of wrestling like we do and
that's the truth there's a legend to
iowa wrestling there's uh it's one of
the most intimidating there's a legend
to john smith it's the same thing
but they can't up for john smith they
get up for oklahoma state
they get up for penn state
my question is okay i'll answer it this
way i'll give you i'll give you an
example in my coaching career i coached
at virginia tech for 22 months
[Music]
we recruited the number one recruiting
class
we got the administration to change
100 percent 180 how they looked at
wrestling
here's the thing and because of how
serious we were and because we weren't
idiots
we were able to do that with our
administration but my point is this
we tried to win
we tried to win even at virginia tech it
wasn't a stepping stone for me it ended
up being one quickly
and looking back on it i was a fool to
think that i'd be there for 20 years but
you believed you would be i did yeah i
did
i did
you